[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
new tips and tricks are difficult to
come by after eight seasons of bond I
Battle Royale
so I thought we'd go through all the
mechanics and mini tactics which work
during season eight some you'll know
some you may have forgotten and some are
unique to season eight so if you're
ready let's do this by the way there are
some great youtubers who regularly
upload tip videos check them out you
won't be disappointed I always ask a
question on these videos this time which
landing location has given you the most
wins for me it's Pleasant Park what
about you write your answers in the
comments and about your favorite landing
spots except for tilted towers because
you guys yes cysts right you ready let's
do this the hamster balls are almost as
annoying as airplanes but have you
mastered moving quickly and making
yourself a hard target to hit give this
a try use the grapple to swing from tree
to tree with a little practice you'll be
on par with your friendly neighborhood
spider-man also many people keep
forgetting that the super monkey balls
can climb mountains so save your Maps
and try not to let your balls drop
nothing there's a joke in there
somewhere
sorry the baller can even drive up
molten lava I know it's a bit specific
that but yeah it can so if you're ever
traveling around in that area keep that
in mind as we're talking about a bit of
locomotion remember to emote when using
a hoverboard to make yourself a harder
target to hit you also looked mighty
fine whilst doing it the worm has to be
the best because of its low profile and
high movement but anything is better
than standing still here's one that
everybody knew except me you can heal
whilst using the hoverboard ya know I'm
an idiot I never tried I simply never
tried now I can arrive even later into
the next circle knowing I can heal
whilst in the stop
[Music]
I'm sure you know this one too but just
in case season 8 introduced the
fantastic cannons for quick and easy
free rotations have you ever tried
wheeling a cannon over a geezer a geyser
the key keys again whatever it's
possible to shoot the cannon towards the
ground and gain even more height you can
also switch positions and then fire
yourself from that cannon mid-air it
actually rivals the quad crusher for
speed if there's no guys are nearby as
long as the cannon is a few levels above
the ground it's possible to do this
trick but in a much smaller way simply
walk off the edge and shoot your cannon
at the ground moving up to quad crashes
we all know to make a ramp to get some
serious air time the problem is getting
shot out means you'll inevitably fall to
your death
we'll try it over a geyser a geyser
whatever not only will you get better
height you'll also be invulnerable to
fall damage so if your ride is about to
explode jump off knowing you're
completely safe general updates in
season eight to see vending machines
completely free to use try to remember
as many spawn points as possible and
look out for a few on each rotation also
when using vending machines take a
closer look at the circle behind the
item it's a timer it shows you when it's
going to switch items I've got to admit
I had never noticed that until this week
visual cues a quick note about the
pirate treasure bags in the themed areas
there are full of metal resources hit
them at every opportunity you get
another spot added in season 8 which is
great for storm resources in a matter of
seconds you can get 500 is up here on
the map there's also a few trees around
if you look hard enough
[Music]
traps are now one button to place and do
not require a floor room or wall tile to
use this is such a hard change to make
due to over a year of muscle memory but
with a little practice instantly
trapping a foe is now even easier
not only our traps a single button press
we use as two are the launch pads so
when that moment comes when your build
is shot out and you're falling to your
imminent death spam the launch pad and
pray that you hit the right angle the
floor isn't flat everywhere on this
island so practice hitting a ramp and
launch pad almost simultaneously to
prevent your death in uneven locations
I'm sure you've also been stuck in a
tree at some point use that same tactic
to prevent fall damage it's possible to
just land on a ramp but the new
technique which I've seen a lot is to
use a ramp and pyramid almost
simultaneously once again to get just
enough height to stop any damage at all
I need to use this because I am stuck in
trees so often there's now a weapon that
can prevent fall damage to the flintlock
pistol it has such a kick that it will
defy gravity for a split second and save
your sorry life here's something which
takes practice but is just as impressive
if you're falling to your death and you
only have a turret in your inventory use
it and if you can land on it perfectly
it will negate all fall damage it's
nothing near as easy to use as a launch
pad but you never know it could save
your life
going back to launchpads for a moment
have you noticed the slowdown when your
glider or parachute is out the fortnight
Deb's changes is quite often but at
present it's painfully slow which can
see you shot full of lead before you
even land it's possible to cheat the
slowdown of a launch pad pull the roof a
few tiles above the launcher if you have
time of course
and once you've done that your head will
bounce off and mess up the animation
making descending much quicker and
easier oh and a general point I'm sure
you already know but just in case
whether you use a geezer geyser whatever
redeploy or a launch pad when you land
spam jump for a free bunnyhop of speed
at this moment is season 8 it's absurd
the speed you can keep doing this on ice
will result in absolutely ridiculous
momentum I firstly can't control it but
this one could be for you
[Music]
we can't have a tips video without a few
ways to get into one by once has this
ever happened to you you've injured
someone and you know they are one hit
from death and you spend so much time
trying to get inside they're built did
you know that placing a pyramid behind
yourself is possible to phase through
the wall and enter the build it's
important the pyramid is incomplete and
flashing this yellow color as once the
wall is destroyed the pyramid will
instantly complete pushing you through
the next turbo build but I really don't
understand why people like to get inside
other people's builds from the other
perspective is so easy to counter if you
see your opponent has set up this
maneuver simply get ready with your
traps the amount of players who will
give you their life because they want to
be Tipu sit back and accept the bounty
another scenario which happens often is
again when fighting a turtling fall when
you've taken their wall a typical player
will build a ramp inside to cover
themselves this can put you on the back
foot as spamming their ramp can be
futile and the good player will edit out
at the top of there one by one and gain
the high ground over you if you have a
turret think about placing it down
inside there one by one this will
instantly break their ramp and is so
unexpected that you should be able to
get a shot off in the panic it's a risk
reward though you are actively giving
them away have you noticed the campfires
have been updated and smoked to give
away when they are being used this will
give you a clue about your enemy's
position in a fight and over time people
will naturally attack anyone buy ones
with smoke around them well this is
where we can bait people place a
campfire down and quickly reposition if
your enemy is paying attention they will
attack the campfire giving you a free
shot look at that you know how to spot
night also do this with permanent
campfires in the game I don't know about
you but I keep forgetting their
functional this season so use them to
fake your poles
as you already know season 8 uses the
confirmed kill mechanic to regain 50
health or shields in squads and duo's if
you down someone and have a few seconds
spare use your healing items before
finishing them the extra 50 stacks on
your current health so boost it before
confirming the elimination the ping
system was added in season 8 which has a
great use cleaning items so far away you
can't see what they bloody are we've all
had that moment when a golden object is
in the distance and it catches our eye
we run over risking attack and what is
it a bloody toad a wasted journey
we can now ping the item at distance and
the pop-up will tell us what it is very
useful indeed
when landing or repositioning with a
glider think about hitting the zip lines
we no longer take fall damage after
dropping from a zipline so attaching and
then quickly dropping can see you hit
the ground first and be looting before
anyone else if this is late-game this is
yet another way to combat the criminally
slow gliders when repositioning another
tips are landing earlier than everyone
else is to glide over the geezers guys'
Jesus whatever after falling from the
battle bus this will allow you to gain
momentum and mobility allowing you to
land first and loop first
so there we have it 30 tips and tricks
to keep you one step ahead of your
enemies in fortnight during season 8
what did I miss to end his a legend
dance to thank those people who use my
code and tomorrow in the four night shop
you guys are absolute like ends to me by
the way we need to figure out a name for
my supporters grenade guards bomb squad
I'm I need help anyway if you want to be
in the next thank-you dance take a
picture when you are using my code and
throw it over to me on Twitter I'm
adding grenade over there once again
thank you for your time and thank you
for your support I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
as always I'll see you next time
[Music]